it's not uh that christmas came early
this week but audience questions comes
early this week because it is a
shortened week with the Thanksgiving
holiday so first question today is from
Aidan Aidan wrote in and said hey David
now that the alt right is more
legitimized with Donald Trump should the
news spend more time refuting crazy
conspiracy theories I have such mixed
feelings about this pad because on the
one hand once you have a movement like
the all right legitimized and in a sense
normalize through the trump presidency
is there not a responsibility to get out
ahead of really concerning hypotheses
some call them conspiracy theories in
order to prevent their spread the
counter to that is are you not
legitimizing crazy conspiracy theories
by giving them more time and addressing
them and this is an age-old question
that we often get if you interview an
extremist are you legitimizing them or
are you exposing them so that more
people will be aware of them and resist
them I don't know that there is a
uniform answer to that question well I
think they already have been legitimized
to some extent because we've had an
election of Donald Trump who is kind of
uh supportive of some of these claims
right on but also I don't know if the
news is the authority to really go after
them because they wouldn't trust their
authority on that they wouldn't they
would believe anything they have to say
yet even if the news and by the news i'm
assuming that aidan means corporate
media right right I if if the if
corporate media is already fundamentally
distrusted by many in the all right or
the trumpets or whoever then is there
really anything to accomplish by
corporate media starting to talk about
these different conspiracy theories
we've not really taken a general
position on this I mean we've had a few
conversations pat on whether individual
stories should be debunked and i've
always seen it as as being a
case-by-case basis where we have to say
okay well can we bring a different
approach to it than what you would hear
on corporate media might we accomplish
anything or get give the clear rational
individuals ammunition in buy ammunition
in facts with which they can then go out
into the real world or the internet or
whatever and push back against
conspiracy theories and that's usually
the barometer that we use but I I mean I
think the answer is for our policy we're
not gonna take a general position we'll
just look individually at what in what
stories come up and whether or not they
need to be refuted yeah I like that I
think that sounds good uh it's also
important to know that the news for a
long time has given credence to some of
these conspiracy theories not
necessarily maybe that 911 was an inside
job but that climate change may not be
man-made they'll double portrayed as
this side there's one thing the says
says the other right and we don't really
have take on it false balance is the
name of that right which is in an
interest to be perceived as not biased
corporate media will say well we'll have
two representatives for the two views on
a particular issue and fifty fifty
representation for views on which there
is a 97 or higher percent consensus
doesn't really make sense it would be
like saying well listen uh even though
most people believe that the score of
last night's Celtics game was 8278 not
everybody believes that so we'll have
someone on to do an analysis based on a
different final score climate change
being man-made is not exactly the same
as last night celtic score but i think
is an analogy pat that's sort of the the
idea that that you're referencing there
so I believe it is very important for
corporate and independent media to keep
a close eye on what narratives and
stories start to develop and decide on a
case by case basis whether they need
attention I do not subscribe to the idea
of ignore it all because I think that in
some cases that actually embolden is
really crazy and unhinged ideas